thank you very much I when I got the
script I was very interested in the
project I knew Gary a little bit before
that I was interested in working Jason
and intrigued sly wrote it and I read it
and I saw that it was a well-constructed
movie and that there was a good villain
that I could have a lot of fun with but
then Gary and I talked a lot about I
thought there were two key things to be
brought out with Gator I think in the
original script I read he you know he
did everything that was in the script
but he was you didn't really care about
his sister he like you know she was
addicted to drugs and he would kind of
just like hold it over her head and so I
went to the book and Gary and I looked
at the book and and and realized that
well in fact there's there's a much more
complex relationship to be had that he
actually loves his sister and cares
about her probably likes her more than
she likes him and she's really taking
maybe speak to this more but I took it
that she kind of is using him because he
can give her drugs and stuff like that
and so he wants to give her everything
that he can and it kills him that he the
thing that she wanted what he knows is
killing her so I thought okay there's a
there's a more complex relationship
that'll that'll help humanize this
character and then the other thing I
thought was with Wynonna's character it
was kind of written
like I was the boss of the relationship
like there's a sex scene in there and it
kind of came at the end of like laying
out the plan to her and it was like the
sexting scene was like the punctuation
in like yeah let's do my plan and then
love sex and I thought I I think it's
more interesting if like he's kind of
insecure about this relationship and
like it turns out she like was seeing
one of the other gangsters before and
like it kind of sets gator and I thought
it would just make it a little bit more
unusual that he could be insecure in
this relationship rather than just like
yeah you know what I mean that she's the
bottom of the relationship until the I
too was interested in looking at the
character not as just a drug addict but
who this girl was
ultimately you know I mean I'm from a
small town and I just thought how
heartbreaking you know to sit in your
room at 15 and 16 and have these dreams
for yourself
and everything I want to get out of this
town one day I want to meet that guy one
day I want to I want to do the things I
want to do and and then flash the point
where you're where you haven't done them
and you're and it's painful and you're
and you're living this pain and how they
can cope and so that's that's ultimately
when you know deciding to do
and started to abuse herself that way so
for for me the interest in playing his
character was connecting to the humanity
and to also not strip her of her dignity
that was totally translating to me I'm
sorry what well I mean they were
diabolical victim actually yeah I I
thought what was sort of interesting
there very interesting was the fact that
that she was actually not doing that she
she had done it but she's part of this
operation that was stealing and to me
that it's as diabolical as he could get
because you she knows what happens to it
hurt you she knows how bad would guess
she knows this destroyed last night and
she's yet she's sober and she's enabling
and getting people so yeah but of course
that comes from you know damage and
severe pain and I think the stuff that
she probably went through Gary and I
talked a lot about like sort of the
backstory and a lot about what these
women had to kind of go through to get
these micro beings which is pretty
horrific actually and very degrading and
there's you can't do something like that
and and not be a damaged person you know
and there's a great quote just in heart
damaged people are the most complicated
they have they because they know how to
survive there's some plate quote love it
and I always I thought that was kind of
very interesting to play someone very
very of damage and but I do think her
relationship with Gator which is
interesting that because I I loved what
James brought I loved that whole idea
that he brought but I I think she's on
the other end of it kind of waiting for
him to call you know wait you get
brought in you know but I did love that
food store I did not hold dynamic
females and that how was it playing
alongside someone younger as her father
playing that and also what was the
difference for you
you acted alongside Sylvester Stallone
but this time behind it was the first
she told me everything I know it's just
so bossy
you would never know right get off the
horse get back on the horse it's like
her the whip marks anyway eventually uh
came around
yeah we had a great time it's uh
something quite you know something quite
sweet when you actually get good
chemistry with somebody and I think we
got very lucky right now as for sly I
mean I have what with him
what three I've done three films with
him so I've got this ever-present voice
Yuri Jason
make sure you do this properly
you know it's a he's always he's always
there putting the fear of God in me so
but I think it's you know he's such a
prolific writer and I think is easier
but easy to forget how many films he's
actually written and you know he really
does care he writes with a lot of heart
and instead of just concentrating on a
couple of characters you know he fills
the whole story with with great roles
and you know I think he said I think I
think he does it very very well
leave your physical transformation and
what it entailed it wasn't you know if
the the physicality was something that
the role you know required yeah she was
someone who who's abusing herself every
day you know and that starts to take a
toll so that you know we my Darien and
myself and the makeup artist wanted to
make sure that she was far gone enough
that there was a real danger to her
physicality and an edginess to her and
discomfort and constant agitation but
that she wasn't so far gone that there
was a there wasn't there was a not a
point of no return you know that we
wanted to make sure that she was going
to be coming back because of her by the
end so it was just figuring out the kind
of volume for her look clearly meth is a
very destructive substance and
and it shows physically very quickly and
it's a quick demise so it was just a
conversation about sort of how you know
how rough we wanted her to look and to
maintain the sense of hope in her as
well but it wasn't something that I
thought twice about you know it was it
was something that was required dad one
thing it is amazing that the cake never
judges this character I think that this
is this is a this easy given caricature
anyone makes it a character is that if
there Kate never once gestured be a bad
person I think it probably my thing was
that by Cassy peaked in high school when
she was 18 and now she's pushing 30
you've got the students this puzzles a
jump here because I think that if they
have like with no silver lining it
though hoping and what do you come how
do you self-medicate so I think that
that's why there's one character the
arcanist would be really is Kate's
family one the actors how was it to see
Jason in action when the bedroom or they
weren't invited
yeah I know it's very it's impressive
you know I mean because you you've had
so much experience in the physicality
and I do think there's an inherent
athletic approach to process of
filmmaking you know I mean it's you know
we're all kind of in the trenches
together and figuring it out and just
the way that you know you approached the
character and athletic process that you
took - that was impressive to me and
he's a real leader you know there's a
enjoy him and optimism
that's very important Isabella you can
answer that can't you well it was
awesome it was a I got to learn a lot
because you just you know went for it
there wasn't a reading or anything I
think that because he has the physical
endurance that were professional I had
to learn from that he's done it for a
while
I'm not saying you're old right sounded
a bit that way yeah
I mean really I gotta give you credit to
Brent berry our designer
I was not here he's in Vancouver and
they got mantis and I think Taylor's big
sin isn't cease it eclectic as DP shot
wings royalty shot
I have a sound they would be thing
people don't realize anything that we're
at work or tell you a few times during
TV pilots and uses amazing salsa very
fast is very important anybody who says
together shoot fast I think that the
combination of Gregory's design and I
think Taylor's work and thinking frankly
like Ethan and constantly everybody look
to be able to give it a level of
authenticity I think you know I really
admire this Winter's Bone last year I
think it felt like it was like one notch
away from being a documentary and my
father was he gonna film they felt it
wasn't again a cartoon encounter
shouldn't really tell the two plays a
replacement fact by the way the the barn
dealers barn which is an amazing scent
that was billed for nothing it wasn't
there it wasn't some location that the
Jason walked in the first day of
shooting he said how does it benefit I
said two weeks I mean literally it's an
astonishing
collaboration between a designer and DP
you know for me to direct to funny
locations rather than looking for like
what's in my head the thing is like is
look around see what's out there and see
like you see a plantation at a farm you
see you know it's stable you say this
could be amazing back in the script
originally it's written to be that the
bad guys know the bad guys arrive like
my car and then once we were scouting
and place like Slidell Ponchatoula and
Manchac miss Texas was amazing buyer who
thought they should come by both so for
me the locations trying to inform how to
shoot mark action oh sorry mark action
I work with mark actually since kiss the
girl sometimes
and a great thing about mark like most
like my crew like Greg and you pay we
don't talk that much she said a lot of
trust irritation their point of view so
with mark my things have been some
indigenous sounds to the table like you
know psaltery you know middle those
ideas are part of the part of the music
landscapes just kind of acknowledging
but yeah I think any mark Zoe's mark
sent a lot of scores an amazing
expresses a very like dynamic bombastic
superior feeling this is much more
intimate yeah rehearse because he went
all out and I didn't have to worry about
him not thank you know my shoulder my
teach anybody but I think I think what
I've learned from teaching is how to
communicate better and the idea that
when I work with my I was just with him
this morning
graduate students like if they want to
get their ID we're trying they're trying
to make movies so it's like they have
ideas and I'm basically just helping
them capture those ideas articulate
those ideas so I am constantly trying
asking them well what do you what are
you going for what do you want to
achieve
and then we'll look at what they've done
well this is what I'm getting from what
you've done is that what you're trying
to say no okay then if you're trying to
say this then I think you might try this
and I think it helps my communication
skills so that I can just go to you know
Gary or whatever and say this is how I
think it should be how do you agree
if so then how do we capture that how do
we achieve that and I guess that's the
connection between my teachings we've
done a lot of prana like straight
through it so I'm like saving it because
I know it's great but you know how do we
convey how do you look back yeah I any
funny stories
couple things together so I heard this
is like my third movie with window or
anything yeah and it's great because he
you know he genuinely you know he
genuinely is such a and I know this word
sometimes used genuinely such an
interesting guy like even in a genuine
good way he genuinely is one of the most
interesting guys that you know I mean
Winona
she's been here this whole time she was
very close with Allen Ginsberg and her
family's close with all the beats and
and I played out on Ginsberg so she told
me that I was gonna get a one of Allen
Ginsberg's t-shirts I it's been another
two years
so I'm Odin Allen Ginsberg t-shirt but
to prepare it you know um I think for me
the key was the other key maybe did go
to your question about the character was
that he didn't we I think it just helps
search the movie if he's not just a bad
guy that's there as a device that he is
somebody that does bad things and you
don't condone his actions but you can
understand why he's doing it and so what
that meant to me was well I think maybe
he shouldn't do the math that this is a
business he sees it as a business and so
when he goes after Jason's character
yeah maybe he has a little fun with the
torture of it but it's more that he sees
this guy this guy is just a
to helping his business to helping him
achieve his dream of same dream that
case care grab getting out of this town
getting just making something of himself
which is something that we all do
whatever our businesses we want to
succeed we want to achieve and so we can
all understand that side of it where he
crosses the line that hopefully none of
us crosses well okay I'll hurt somebody
else in order to achieve my dream so we
don't go with them there but it's like
you can understand the human motivation
behind what you're doing and so that's
why I thought like well the meth is just
it's just his way it's just it's just
what he found it's the way that he
thinks he can get out of this this
weekend little town and and so I didn't
need to really know like what it was you
know to do math or anything like that we
just had you know police consultants on
there to tell us how the meth lab should
look and what kind of things I should be
pulling in dénia whatever and you know
that was it
Kate takes the one who had to kind of do
that kind of hardcore research
no it's only because you know I wanted
to wear a brown wig and slaw wanted me
in a blond wig and we just had a bit of
a different disagreement there so yeah I
mean a lot of things put the frighteners
up me but I won't discuss what they are
you might be put them through my
letterbox later this evening so yeah I
try to keep it under my hat
I think Jason does all of his own stunts
I'm pretty sure at least most of them I
don't my gosh
my guy gets really beaten up and there's
a stunt guy that was just happy to do
that but no I mean I've done a lot of
I've done a lot of movies with fight
scenes and you know when you're working
with somebody that's good in it and it's
it's fight scenes are really like I
think they're more like dances than they
are fights because you're depending on
your partner to do the right move at the
right time and it's not about it's it's
yes a tough person or somebody that
knows what they're doing will look
better in a fight scene but it's also a
lot to do with the other person and so
when we did we had one fight scene in
the movie and it was like yeah okay this
is it's great I feel I've actually I'm
not scared here I feel great here
because you know Jason knows what I'm
not gonna get hurt where is like
somebody that's hasn't done a lot of
fight scenes is not tough and probably
like hit my hand with the Soul
you know or whatever no what is it
Oh bullying oh cool
I gotta see my audition I could get a PI
something not to crack I can tell him -
I bullied Isabella
like every day like during the takes
that was actually really hard for me
because she's she's really tough and
such a trooper but - you know handle
right you know the idea that was you
know she's very careful and she you know
I remember at one point you even told me
to to make a cold word because the theme
was that I was supposed to stab her in
the hand at the screwdriver and I guess
I was in the cargo part of the boat and
so the topic supposed to slam and I was
supposed to go like this anyways in his
rehearse it was careful but it was and
so I just you know he's in that way I
guess
and I was like Palomino yeah if you're
really scared
that's the kliebert was like I'd like it
if you are because you know she's
supposed to be screaming in the sea but
I didn't want her to be screaming but
yeah that was and plus I was also in
high-heeled boots which was tough doing
all of that to her on the baby yeah that
was really tough Gary but she said she
was Isabella's really amazing really
really amazing I was he was asked about
the idea of her being on the set all the
violence but actually weeks ago the
whirlings were screening the movie and
this guy brought in his five-year-old
daughter yeah see this movie I mean
being the movies one thing that's kind
of easy because like the idea to bring a
case my fear is people do that you know
these question is for games you are
always right
how do you answer that I don't know you
know I I was acting over a decade and I
and then I went back to school and I and
nobody in my world thought that was like
they thought okay if it makes you happy
but nobody thought it was like a great
idea like oh okay but that means you
can't work as much and like you know and
you're gonna learn get an English degree
what is that gonna do you already have a
career like why are you doing that
nobody was like that excited about it
but I was very it was very important to
me and so I had to fight for that I had
to fight to carve that out and make that
part of my life and now now it's part of
my life I teach here in LA one one day a
week and I'm doing a movie in Vancouver
and and it's just kind of part of the
thing now I'm very fortunate that I can
arrange things that way that I get to do
everything now sometimes things conflict
I can't do something at a certain time
but more or less I get to I get to do
both in it and it's very satisfying you
know I and I don't need tons of time you
know dick like goof around because when
I make movies you know and when I do my
own projects it's like all the people I
love all my friends all my the closest
people in my life are working on those
projects so and there's no relationship
that I find that's closer than a
creative relationship so I get to have
the most intense kind of relationships
with all my friends wall were working
because we get to do the best jobs in
the world and I
these movies with you and work with you
Jay who is your teacher and these I know
these this group of people and there
they are amazing and I have seen it's
quite something you know she's talking
about like a lot of my friends from
anyway you know what happened to Luther
like oh I have them you know there were
a couple black kittens that were doubles
and I I adopted them so I have them now
their names all right Mac Mac Mac's in
Luxor the sisters
you won't thank you so much
you all are excused - great so thank you
so much and if you'll just let them go
they have tons rather than stones still
do so thank you